this is Sal and I'm here again with my
good friend dr. Mahadevan from Stanford
Medical School and what are we looking
at this is this is a mildly disturbing
yeah what we're looking at here is a
picture of the scene of an auto rickshaw
accident in India and what you can see
is a bashed up auto rickshaw which is a
form of transportation like a taxi in
India and likely the driver there on the
ground being attended to by an emergency
medical technique if you take this
picture no this was taken by one of the
emergency medical technicians or EMTs on
an ambulance in India to sort of show
the impact of the scene wow wow and so
and why are we looking at this picture
well we're looking at this picture to
demonstrate or to talk about the
importance of trauma as a health issue
across the globe and and how we need to
pay more attention to it and and you
know traumas a word that you know has an
everyday language use what how do how do
you all refer to trauma there's a
technical term trauma we talk about
trauma we're talking about injuries
specifically car accidents stabbings
gunshot wounds Falls those are the
things that when we talk about trauma
what we're relating to ice and this is
this is what the emergency rooms all
about exactly one of our roles is to
provide care to the victims of trauma
usually we try to get to them early on
so that we can affect their outcomes and
so when ambulances come from accident
scenes they are bringing patients
usually who are victims of trauma I see
I see and we have to slide down here
what what is what is what is this about
this shows a map of the world and what
we can see here is if green is good so
if you live in a place like the United
States or Europe Australia or China
where you're where it's green that means
your chance of dying from trauma or from
an injury is much less than the areas
that are orange like Africa and yeah
well one thing that I mean what you said
China I'm impressed is actually in that
bucket that they're because they're not
you know they're not always considered
fully developed their kind of on their
the rapid growth too but they are pretty
good from a trauma point of view from
this particular study in this graph
Japan and China
are doing comparably to the United
States yeah japan i would expect I'm in
Japan but China that's good I mean I
that's very good they were already kind
of First World status in terms of trauma
response and unity the Olympics I guess
it's Esther no I know their first of all
many things but it's yeah well that's
good that speaks well of the Chinese and
sorry I interrupted you no no and and so
what we really are trying to focus on is
green is great and they're doing fine
and what we're really trying to focus on
are the areas that are orange like most
of the African subcontinent right India
and the Indian subcontinent is red which
has the highest mortality and all okay
Soviet Union so that is I mean this is
perplexing because I would have guessed
if you would ask me before looking this
that China and the Soviet Union would
have been comparable or not so being in
Russia now would have been comparable
but they're at opposite and it's worse
than Africa yeah surprising to me as
well and as do we know why I really
don't know why probably what we're going
to talk about which is a lack of access
to emergency care and also one of the
things that's really worked in our favor
and advantage in this country is the use
of safety devices and and justice kinds
of safety tools we have on our highway
system and roads wow wow okay well
fascinating fascinating and so this is
what we this is what your kind of one of
your missions in life is to address this
issue that that's on the slide right
here this disparity absolutely our goal
is really to see the entire globe look
green as opposed to just certain parts
of it and so what we're hoping to do is
take the knowledge that we've gained the
systems that we've developed in the
green countries and bring them to the
red and orange and yellow countries to
try to decrease the number of deaths
right for for cases like that auto
rickshaw accident that we just we just
saw and hopefully that guy turned out
turned out well but for him okay so we
have some other stuff down here what is
what what is this telling us this really
shows us that that the people that died
from from trauma from injury are our
people like you and I can I can still
say you and I because I'm only 44 and
that fits in that yes that group there
but if you're under the age of 44 you
have the highest likelihood of dying
from trauma
as opposed to see right here so this let
me let me make sure I can digest this is
age distribution of global injury
related mortality so that's death
exactly we're talking about this is in
the year 2000 and right this is one of
the biggest buckets 15 to 29 and then 30
to 44 because we're writing our auto
auto rickshaws more writing motorcycles
without helmets or riding in our cars
talking on our cell phone or without her
seat belts or absolute this is global
this includes even the US and this data
this is global it's everybody right
right right mortalia this is number of
deaths percentage of total okay so if
someone if you know someone died due to
injury related there's a twenty-five
percent chance that they were a little
less than that that they were probably
in this age group and then another 25
roughly percent chance that they were in
this age group that's right so over half
of the patients or roughly half the
patients between the ages of 15 and 44
which are the young productive patients
that are contributing to society right
right fascinating fascinating I'm I wear
my helmet very good online okay and what
is this is this is fascinating what is
this telling us this is a very famous
diagram that looks at the tri modal
distribution of death and basically what
it shows is right after a severe
accident or trauma it you have a
50-percent likelihood of dying and
that's usually from some kind of
devastating injuries some devastating
head injury or aortic injury that is not
survivable so these people usually die
within either instantly or within the
first few minutes after a trauma and I
see so this is like on this axis someone
this is where the injury occurred
exactly that we're moving forward in
time right over here exactly moving
forward in time and this is what you're
talking about this fifty percent this
fifty percent is these are people it's a
major injury and even in a modern
healthcare system it might be difficult
you might not even get to them in time
because this is in minutes exactly does
exactly so this this is some devastating
injury like you said somebody was not
wearing their helmet and and
realistically we're not gonna be able to
get to them in time and it's doubtful
that we could do anything for these
people right whether you're in the first
world or or in the developing world
exactly and so our focus here would be
on prevention right right right
obviously right right and then what are
these other
groups the next sort of distribution of
death is this thirty percent group which
is in from minutes to hours and and
these are the patients that we're really
trying to get at these are the patients
and we use a term called the golden hour
which is that first hour after injury if
we can get to those patients and get
them to skilled healthcare both in the
field and at the hospital we can affect
their outcomes and when I say that what
I mean is we can save their lives
potentially all right and this is where
it becomes really relevant in this idea
of kind of global health these people
are getting saver for the most part
they're getting saved in the developed
world where we have good kind of
emergency response systems and things
like that and then the doctors are
trained in emergency medicine but in a
lot of the parts of the world they don't
Matt not have a good ambulance system or
911 system and then even when they get
to a hospital they might not have a
proper emergency room absolutely true
and what's the staggering statistic is
if you look at that group of patients
that those thirty percent in a developed
world their chance of dying is about six
percent in the undeveloped world or
developing world their chance of dying
is six times higher it's 36 lot Wow okay
yeah so that's a major so a game injury
yes different location different country
different outcome for them and your
senses there's there's some basic things
that they can do to get this thirty-six
percent a lot closer to the the six
percent exactly and it's exactly the
things that you alluded to development
of an emergency medical services or an
ambulance system that can take the
patient to the hospital education
development of education development of
systems a trauma systems that we have
here in the US and in other parts of the
world incorporating those into the way
they care for those patients can can
reduce that number from thirty six
percent all right now in terms of
absolute numbers i mean we're talking
about if if if the developing world were
down to you know single digits we're
talking about thousands or maybe million
i mean we're talking about thousands of
people every day every day thousands of
people not done house especially these
young people in this distribution right
over here these people were probably
supporting their families absolutely
absolutely and and it just it's just a
matter of the things that we allude to
thousands every day thousands every day
Wow and what and what's this last this
last
group right over here this last group is
a group that typically dies days or
weeks later in the intensive care
setting and these patients usually die
from overwhelming sepsis like an
infection or sepsis is like a bacterial
infection in the blood and overwhelming
better or something like multi-organ
failure so all of their organs start to
shut down and again be but so so this is
really the sweet spot where you want to
focus your your emergency medicine
because this this is you know this is
not dependent on the EMS system and
basic processes and things like that but
this is stuff that you can really really
start to exactly exactly well it really
is important that's it and just one more
one more fact as time progresses right
now the number one killer of people in
the world is cardiovascular disease you
know in 2020 just nine years from now
trauma will be the number two killer
worldwide of all patients 2020 it'll be
trauma it'll be he said number number
two number two right after right after
cardiovascular disease and we know right
now on a daily basis 16,000 people die
every day from trauma around the 16,000
people and that that's that's based on
the trend that we are on right now if we
get this number down to six percent
maybe it might not be number two
hopefully that's our goal that's that's
the goal that's to go wow wow it's
mind-boggling